alors humour rire spectacle fait
chansons éric carrière eric carrière et
francis ginibre deux hurluberlus
toulousain autrement dénommé les
chevaliers du fiel
mais au fait ça veut dire quoi les
chevaliers du fiel alors c'est bien de
notre premier spectacle qui était un
détournement d'avion prenez une salle en
otage et donc c'est un rapport au
célèbre feuilleton qui s'appelait les
chevaliers du ciel et le fiel tout le
monde sait ce que c'est dans notre
région quoi c'est ça c'est un rapport à
l'acidité de notre humour
voilà alors ça c'était francis ginibre
ça c'est éric carrière il paraît qu'il
est coauteur de du spectacle des ventes
mais j'écris pour l'évent pages écrit
pour tout un tas de tout un tas de gens
comme ça et puis évidemment pour les
chevaliers du fiel
donc les meilleurs gars que je garde
pour nous c'est pour vous dire et donc
là on vient de faire un nouveau
spectacle s'appelle dynamite pour tout
nouveau donc c'est la création 93 et
qu'on présente donc en ce moment à
toulouse pour bien commencer bien finir
l'année 92 bien commencé avec 93 il
paraît que l'année dernière vous étiez à
l'olympia c'était un grand moment pour
vous ça non oui enfin l'a fait deux fois
on l'a fait en 90 justement en première
partie des ventes
et puis on a remis ça comme ça a très
bien marché l'année suivante avec michel
courtemanche et un canadien
et ça c'est une super expérience quand
même la scène de l'olympia c'est
vraiment magique
ben c'est bien alors donc que votre
spectacle se poursuit jusqu'au 31
décembre et théâtre de la source pour
réserver ses places parce que je réserve
évidemment et puis il ya deux spectacles
en fait j'en ai à 20h30 qui est
l'assassin dans la salle numéro deux
c'est une enquête policière la chute la
suite du 1 donc qui est donc à une
comédie de polars qu'on a fait à avignon
à paris l'an dernier quatre mois et
qu'on représente pour la dernière fois à
toulouse donc ça si on veut le voir ce à
20h30 et puis tous les jours à 22h
dynamite laugnac dynamite alors
justement on va écouter un petit extrait
il paraît que vous allez dénoncé une
grande cause
oui on écoute
tu es là public qu'on me donne des
salles pleines et gelé viderait je
voudrais dénoncer une grande cause qui
me tient particulièrement à coeur
chaque année on les tue au couteau dans
la nuit sans même qu'elle puisse pousser
un cri
[Musique]
à chaque année le scandale se reproduit
on les tue dans la nuit elles étaient 26
ans elle était de 12 aïn les huîtres de
marennes et les huîtres de marennes ou
les huîtres de marennes suite
[Musique]
pipi
que tu sois est fine de creil où que tu
sois spécial que cesse le scandale qu'on
arrête de nous prendre pour des cons
du côté de marennes oléron tatra matt
ward hulot ébouillanté battoir crevettes
mutilé battoir toutes ont asphyxié à
thouars hommage mutilés à toi toi bats
toi
toi bats
toi bats toi à toi bats toi bats toi toi
patois
[Musique]